so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your interim host
Carl Smallwood that's Carl with a K and
Smallwood with a a small and then a w
and today we're talking about Paul John
nolles the Casanova killer now
ordinarily I really don't like making
content that concerns like True Crime I
was informed by the people behind the
scenes the producers and the owners of a
channel that the True Crime genre is
popular with the specific demographic of
women age 25 to 35 and since that's a
demographic I would like to be popular
with I decided to make an exception
speaking of which links to my socials
can be found below as can the socials of
the author of today's video Radu
Alexander without further Ado let's get
to
it Paul John NOS had a a way with people
especially with women his charms his
good looks made people trust him just
innately and he could lower their guard
British journalist Sandy forks for
example once described NOS as and I
quote tall well over six foot broad
shoulders narrow hip and as Slender as a
wraith and a sort of like a cross
between Robert Redford and Ryan O'Neal
and as you will soon find out she had a
fairly shall we say unique personal
perspective on this rather ruthless
killer all of this though was for show
beneath that affable confident Persona
was hiding something altogether darker
ever since he was a small boy Paul NOS
had decided that the rules and laws
weren't really meant for him there were
sort of guidelines he could choose not
to follow and that he could just take
whatever he wanted and do whatever he
pleased to anyone he felt like his
entire life was one steady escalation of
brutality and sadism from petty theft to
robbery to sex crimes and ultimately to
murder a four-month long Savage Killing
Spree left at least 18 people dead and
in custody no showed no remorse or
regret over his numerous crimes and soon
after left the world the only way he
knew how
violently
Paul John noes was born on April 17th
1946 in Orlando California the son of
Thomas Jefferson nolles and Bonnie
Strickland we can't really tell you much
about his childhood we only really know
that nolles bounced around a few foster
homes in his Youth and that he started
stealing from a very very early age then
when he was 18 He escalated things quite
considerably after being stopped for
questioning during a traffic incident by
a police officer in Jacksonville Florida
nolles held the patrolman at gunpoint
and kidnapped him eventually he released
the officer unharmed but you can't
really get away with kidnapping a police
officer and have nothing bad happen to
you so the criminal was arrested and
convicted and on April 21st 1965 the
19-year-old NS was sentenced to 5 years
in prison for kidnapping which seems
rather
low right especially when it's like your
first crime no one's first crime is
aggravated kidnapping of a police
officer he's wild and speaking of which
Nolls was released early because it was
his first arrest rest but Noles would
become very familiar with the inside of
a prison cell over the next decade he
spent more time Behind Bars than he did
as a free man serving on average seven
months a year mostly for thefts and
burglaries while doing a threeyear
stretch in Rayford Florida noes started
putting his charm to work on the pen pal
program he began corresponding with a
divorced woman from California named
Angela kovic she visit him in prison a
few times and before you knew it he
popped the question and she said yes and
she even paid his lawyer fees to secure
Nos and early leas and found him his job
as a sign Peter what could possibly go
wrong I say 4 minutes into a 20 minute
long video about a serial killer after
being paroled in May of 1974 noes
traveled to San Francisco to meet with
his new betrodd Angela was finally with
the man of her dreams but fortunately
for her her survival instincts kicked in
and they began screaming girl get the
hell out and after only a few days
together she realized that NOS was not
the kind of man she thought he was she
got a sneak peek at the darkness hiding
underneath a veneer of friendliness and
seduction and she understood that he was
trouble later stating that a fiance
projected an aura of fear kovic broke up
with Nos and survived her encounter with
the man who had come to be known as the
Casanova killer for reasons that will
become abundantly clear in about 5
minutes others were not so lucky
according to his own confession on the
day he got dumb noes took out his anger
on a few unfortunate residents of San
Francisco and killed three random people
in a single night police could never
verify these three victims or if the
crime occurred as noes described but it
is worth pointing out at this stage that
NOS invest to a lot more killings than
the authorities could ever confirm and
we only know of 18 people who were
definitively killed by NS during his
crime spree but he would in prison
confess to of murdering up to 35 and
what made NOS so terrifying a criminal
is that he killed pretty much
indiscriminately he would kill people of
all ages using different weapons in
their homes on the street in the woods
there was no pattern to what he did
which made it very difficult to
establish an accurate timeline of what
he did or figure out what he was going
to do next and whether or not these
three would have been his first murders
we cannot say but we certainly know they
weren't his last so even if those were
made up by Nolls to just taunt the
authorities it would not be long until
the brutal killer would begin his murder
spree in Earnest after his Rampage in
San Francisco that may or may not have
happened no's returned to the familiar
surroundings of Jacksonville Florida
there he got into a bar fight and
stabbed a bartender on July 26th
1974 police arrested him and placed him
in custody but noes managed to break out
of his detention cell and make his
Escape poor John noes was now on the run
and would show little Mercy for the
people who were unfortunate enough to
cross his
path no's first confirmed kill took
place the same night he escaped from
custody he broke into the house of a
65-year-old woman named Alex Curtis
subduing her and leaving her bound and
gags he ransacked her home for valuables
once he's finished robbing her NOS got
into her car and drove off into the
night leaving Curtis to choke to death
on her own gag and that killing may have
been unintentional with n simply just
not caring what happened to his victim
after he left her home but the next
murders he committed were not only
completely targeted but showed that the
heartless NOS had no real compassion for
anyone who crossed his path his next
victim was a 13-year-old girl named IMA
jeene Sanders who disappeared from
Warner Robbins Georgia on August 1st
while hitchhiking her remains were not
found until 2 years later in the woods
in Peach County but it wouldn't be until
2011 that she was definitively
identified using DNA and it gets worse
from here folks so yeah what I would
like to say that's about as bad as it
get that's it isn't again I say this 8
minutes into a 20 minute recording about
a serial killer so on that very same day
noes tried dumping the car he stole from
Alice Curtis since the authorities were
looking into it but two young girls had
The Misfortune of seeing him commit the
crime these were lilan and melet
Anderson who were 11 and 7 years old at
the time respectively the remorseless
NOS had no Quan about kidnapping and
strangling them both to death burying
their bodies in a swamp just one day
after this NOS forced his way into the
house of a for 49-year-old marjerie how
and did the same thing he did to Alice
Curtis except this time he did not leave
her to fate or chance and strangled her
before robbing the home he repeated the
act on August 23rd when he broke into
the home of a 24-year-old Cathy Su pus
in Musa Georgia and strangled her with
the telephone cord Pi had a
three-year-old son in the home who was
thankfully left on hand one of the
exceptionally few cases where NS
displayed a shred of Mercy September was
a big month for the murderous Drifter as
he passed through Ohio Alabama
Mississippi Texas and Nevada leaving
bodies behind in all states some of
these victims were simply people in the
wrong place at the wrong time for
example there's an elderly couple called
EMT and Lois Johnson who were killed
while out camping near Eli Nevada Sly
NOS AB booked A 42-year-old Charlene
Hicks while she was on the side of the
road and dumped her body in a rest stop
in suen Texas other victims fell prey to
the charm and affability of the man who
had come to be known as the Casanova
killer who could turn on the charm
seemingly whenever he wanted to
32-year-old William Bates was lasting
aive share Shing a few drinks with NOS
in a roadside pub near Lima Ohio he was
having a good time and perhaps thinking
he'd made himself a new friend but Noles
was only interested in one thing bait's
car and he strangled his drinking buddy
dumped him in the woods and drove off in
his new ride in Birmingham Alabama noes
made the acquaintance of a 49y old
beautician called an dwon the PA
traveled together for a while and we
don't know if dwson went along willingly
or was simply one of no's of the
kidnapping victims it kind of was his
thing either way it made a little
difference once nolles grew tired of her
and Dawson suffered the same fate as
everybody else the killer strangled her
and discarded her body in the
Mississippi River where it remained
undiscovered for a further three years
in October NOS passed through
Connecticut and Virginia before
returning to his classic hunting grounds
in Georgia and Florida in Malboro
Connecticut NS broke into the home of
Karen wine who lived with her teenage
daughter Dawn he murdered both women
simply for the thrill of it because he
didn't steal anything from the house
leaving the authorities to conclude that
he simply killed them because he wanted
to in fact the only thing he took from
the home besides those two women's lives
was a tape recorder which he later used
to record a long confession giving
detailed accounts of the 14 murders he
committed in eight different states NOS
then gave the tape to a lawyer in
Florida and it was later used in his
trial to identify some of his victims
and we're not really sure why NOS did
this it certainly wasn't because he
intended to give himself up or stopped
killing or because he start to feel
remorse just a few days later he entered
the home of Doris hovley and Woodford
Virginia and shot her with her husband's
rifle and we're still not done back in
Florida still driving William bit's
stolen car NOS picked up to Hitchhikers
in Key West he obviously had some
criminal intentions in mind but was
pulled over by a policeman for a traffic
violation The Hitchhikers might have
thought this was bad luck but they
didn't know how wrong they were and even
though the cop let NS off with just a
warning The Experience threw him off his
game at least enough that he decided to
drop off his riding companions in Miami
safe and sound again this is an
exceedingly rare example of someone got
close to this man and lived to tell the
tale
no start in November with two double
murders he is strongly suspected of
killing a young hitchhiking couple near
makon Georgia on November 2nd then a few
days later noes once again turned on his
murderous charm and befriended a man he
met in A Bar Named Carwell car the two
got on so well that car invited his new
companion back home to spend the night
but this would be a decision that would
cost him very dearly the very next day
car was found bound and naked with 27
stab wounds on his body from a pair of
scissors found in his own home while his
teenage daughter Mandy had been
strangled with a pair of her own nylon
stockings a couple of days later nolles
was prowling the bars of Atlanta looking
for a new Target which is where he made
the acquaintance of the aforementioned
Sandy Forks a British journalist with
the Daily Express who was in America
hoping to score some big interviews as
we've said before she thought that Noles
was a very handsome man and the two hit
it off immediately Forks knew him as
Daryl golden no no ego there and the two
not only went home together but they
spent the next several days together as
well they reportedly tried having sex
several times signs but NOS could not
shall we say rise to the occasion Forks
would later speculate that the killer
was impotent with a willing participant
but we don't really know for sure
despite feeling extreme frustration NOS
allowed the journalist to leave unharmed
and it's not really clear why is he had
no Quan about killing people for far
less in the past and it is suggested
that he let Forks live because he
figured she could be his ticket to
notoriety we asked talking about him in
a YouTube video that we're hoping lots
of people click so I I guess and
reportedly Nolls did ask Fork several
times if she ever intended to write a
book and even suggested that she could
write one about him which she did a few
years later titling it UNC creatively
killing time after the cardal murders
NOS was starting to feel the net Titan
around him on November 16th 1974
patrolman Charles Campbell pulled him
over near Perry Florida unfortunately
for him NOS was quicker to react and
stole his gun driving away in the very
cop car that Campbell pulled him over in
with Campbell in the back as a hostage
because because two were always better
than one NOS used the siren pull over a
random motorist named James Mayer took
him hostage as well and when he reached
a wooded area he then handcuffed both
men to a tree and shot them in the back
of the head don't worry NOS gets his the
following day NOS ran into a police
roadblock outside of stocksbridge
Georgia literally as in he tried
smashing through it but toted his
vehicle and fled on foot through the
woods for several hours he managed to
evade the police police dogs and even
several helicopters until he ran into a
civilian named David Clark NOS had hoped
that he could use his tried and true
charm to convince or perhaps coerced the
man into helping him but he was out of
luck on that one Clark was a Vietnam vet
armed with a shotgun and he knew exactly
who was stood in front of him the
murderer known as the Casanova killer he
held NOS at gunpoint until the police
arrived he was finally in custody once
NOS had been arrested he confessed to
killing 18 different people but later
boasted of committing up to 35 murders
again we we don't know exactly how many
people NOS killed but 18 is the number
that we definitively know for sure it's
likely that he killed many other people
during his spree cuz that was yeah that
was kind of his thing for a while so it
was pretty obvious that his trial would
be a mere formality at that point they
literally caught him red-handed and they
had his own words as a confession but
his case never even got as far as a
trial because on December 18th 1974 NOS
was been transferred to a new facility
in a car with Sheriff ER Lee and Georgia
Bureau of Investigations agent Ronnie
Angel NOS made a grab for Lee's gun but
this time he did not win out ancient
Angel drew his out sidearm and shot Paul
NOS three time in the chest killing him
on the spot and thus end of the tale the
Cova killer so I hope everybody out
there found this video to be educational
entertaining and informative I certainly
found the script to be all three of
those things and while the subject
matter is something that's uh not my cup
of tea I am aware that the true crime
genre and the Darkly fascinating are
something that is interesting to people
out there so if you are one of the
people who enjoyed this video let us
know by leaving a like comment subscribe
and I feel so bad saying that in a video
where a guy admitt to killing 18
people it's so weird my job is so weird
sometimes I'm at a Christmas party later
I was wearing a Christmas jumper before
I started recording this video it's so
it's just over there I can see my
Christmas presents in the corner of the
room there a there's a
there's a tree in everything thank you
to everyone for watching go give the
author of this piece some love R
Alexander you can find him on the
socials link below I'm sure they would
appreciate being told that their efforts
to research such a maab and awful case
weren't in vain and yeah just to
everyone out there um go out there and
have the day you deserve and just yeah I
never know how to wiend these
ever